[Music]
Well, hello everyone. Welcome to our
program. I'd like to know my associates
are out on the floor of the general
conference session doing interviews and
contacting people. So, I will be uh
working on these questions by myself
today.
As I mentioned, we are presently at the
general conference session which takes
place every five years and we are in the
city of St. Louis. Uh all of our crew is
here and uh we're getting acquainted
with so many people who appreciate our
ministry who tune in on a regular basis.
Today we have some very interesting
questions. I'm not sure how many of them
we're going to be able to answer because
there's a lot to say about them. But
before we begin, we do want to have a
word of prayer to ask the Lord to bless
us as we try to answer these questions.
So I invite you to bow your heads with
me as we pray. Father in heaven, we come
before you to ask for the help of the
Holy Spirit now as I attempt to answer
these questions from your holy word. I
ask Lord that uh the answers will be
satisfactory to the person who asked
them as well as those who will be
watching this program. We thank you for
the presence of the Holy Spirit here and
we know that you will bless those who
watch this program because we ask it in
the precious and most holy name of
Jesus. Amen.
Well, the first question that we have
today and as I mentioned uh we might not
have time to answer another question but
if we do we will attempt to do so. This
question is from Lizzy
and it's a question that has come up um
many times in the course of my ministry
and uh so we want to take a look at this
particular question which comes up
especially from the Protestant world to
Adventists.
This is the question. I have a question
about Ephesians 24-16.
Many Sundayeping Protestants use this
passage to claim that the Ten
Commandments were abolished at the
cross.
Could you please help me understand the
correct interpretation of this passage?
So, basically, uh, this person Lizzy
wants an answer concerning the meaning
of Ephesians 2:14 through 18.
Now what we want to do is consider the
context of what the Apostle Paul is
dealing with here. Every text needs to
be studied within its context.
In this passage, the Apostle Paul is
dealing with the relationship between
Jew and Gentile. There was a wall of
separation between the Jews and the
Gentiles in the times of Christ as well
as in the times of the Apostle Paul. So,
what I want to do is begin in Ephesians
2 verse 11 and read all the way through
verse 18. And you'll see that it's
dealing with the conflict between Jews
and Gentiles and the ceremonies of the
Jews which were not celebrated by the
Gentiles. Beginning in verse 11
here, Paul is speaking to Gentiles.
Therefore, remember that you once
Gentiles in the flesh, who are called
uncircumcision,
by what is called the circumcision, made
in the flesh by hands, that at that time
you were without Christ, being aliens
from the commonwealth of Israel, and
strangers from the covenants of promise,
having no hope, and without God in the
world. But now things change because of
Christ. Verse 13. But now in Christ
Jesus, you who were once very far off
have been brought near by the blood of
Christ. In other words, Christ makes all
the difference. Christ tears down the
barriers between Jew and Gentile. Let's
go to verse 14. For he himself that is
Jesus is our peace who has made both
that is Jew and Gentile one and has
broken down the middle wall of
separation. So there was a separation
between Jew and Gentile and that
separation is torn down by Jesus Christ.
How did he do it? Verse 15.
having abolished in his flesh the
enmity, the enmity between Jew and
Gentile, that is the law of commandments
contains in contained in ordinances
so as to create in himself. Here is the
thought once again, one new man from the
two, thus making peace, and that he
might reconcile them both to God in one
body through the cross, thereby putting
to death the enmity. Verse 17, and he
came and preached peace to you who were
a far off, and to those who were near,
that is to Jew and Gentile. For through
him, that is through Jesus, we both Jew
and Gentile, have access by one spirit
to the father. So you see here in this
passage, the apostle Paul is discussing
the relationship with Jew between Jew
and Gentile. And in his time there was a
wall of separation between Jew and
Gentile. And it had to do with the
ordinances that the Jews had. Now, what
specific ordinance is the Apostle Paul
addressing here? We don't have to guess.
He's not discussing the moral law of the
Ten Commandments. He's discussing the
ceremonial law of the Jews, which
separated them from the Gentiles. It
should not have been that way, but
that's the way that it was. How do we
know that Paul is dealing with a
specific issue here? Because in verse 11
it says, "Therefore remember that you
once Gentiles in the flesh who are
called uncircumcision by what is called
the circumcision made in the flesh by
hands." So here the apostle Paul's
saying that that which separates the Jew
and the Gentile is the right of
circumcision. And of course, you could
add the other ceremonies that pointed
forward to the days of Christ. So when
it speaks here about Christ abolishing
in his flesh the enmity, that is the law
of commandments contained in in
ordinances,
it's not referring to the ten
commandments. It's referring
specifically to the right of
circumcision which was a wall of
separation between the Jews and the
Gentiles.
You know, specifically we find in verse
that there was that the Gentiles were
alienated
from Jesus Christ mainly because of this
wall of partition which was created by
the Jews themselves.
It says there in verse 12 that at the
that time you were without Christ
being aliens from the commonwealth of
Israel and strangers from the covenants
of promise having no hope and without
God in the world. It should not have
been that way because God established
the Jewish nation to reach out to the
entire world. You can read it uh for
example in Isaiah 49:6
not only to lift up the tribes of
Israel. He called his people to be a
light to the nations of the world. But
unfortunately the Jews had established
this wall of partition between them and
the Gentiles between the circumcised and
the uncircumcised.
By the way, this is also the issue that
came up at the Jerusalem Council.
If you have your Bibles and you go with
me to Acts chapter 15, you're going to
find what the issue was there in the
days of the Apostle Paul.
There were Judaizers who insisted that
the Gentiles needed to be circumcised.
And if they were not circumcised, they
could not be considered uh heirs of the
covenant. They could not be considered
members of God's special chosen people.
That was the issue that was dealt with
at the Jerusalem Council. I want to read
Acts 15 and verse 1. We can't go through
the entire story of the Jerusalem
Council, but we'll read a few verses.
Acts 15 and verse one says, "And certain
men came down from Judea and taught the
brethren, unless you are circumcised
according to the custom of Moses, you
cannot be saved." So, see, there's the
wall of separation. Unless the Gentiles
are circumcised, they cannot belong to
God's special people. That is the issue.
The issue is not the Ten Commandments.
The issue is the ceremonial right of
circumcision that was a special
prescription that God gave to the Jewish
nation that incorporated them into God's
chosen people. That is the issue and the
ceremonial law itself. Now the Jerusalem
council made the decision to not require
the Gentiles to be circumcised in order
to belong to God's chosen people. Let's
go down to verse 22 of Acts chapter 15.
Then it pleased the apostles and elders
with the whole church to send chosen men
of their own company to Antioch with
Paul and Barnabas, namely Judas, who was
also named Barsabas and Silas leading
men among the brethren. And then of
course uh we find in the following
verses verse 23 they wrote this letter
by them the apostles the elders and the
brethren to the brethren who are of the
gentiles in Antioch Syria and Cissia.
Greetings. And now comes the
announcement of what the Jerusalem
council decided. Verse 24. Since we have
heard that some who went out from us
have troubled you with words, unsettled
your souls, saying you must be
circumcised and keep the law. Talking
about the law of circumcision, it's not
talking about the ten commandments to
whom we gave no such commandment. It
seemed good to us being assembled with
one accord to send chosen men to you
with our beloved Barnabas and Paul, men
who have risked their lives for the name
of the Lord Jesus Christ. We have
therefore sent Judas and Silas, who will
also report the same things by word of
mouth. For it seemed good to the Holy
Spirit, and to us, to lay upon you no
greater burden than these necessary
things, that you abstain from things
offered to idols, from blood, from
things strangled, and from sexual
immorality. If you keep yourselves from
these, you will do well. In other words,
the Jerusalem Council decided that it
was not indispensable for the Gentiles
to be circumcised to belong to God's
people. That is the law of ordinances
that is being spoken of in the book of
Ephesians. The issue has nothing to do
with the Ten Commandments. I want to
read a statement by Albert Barnes
who was a Presbyterian Bible
commentator. you know, he's from a long
time ago, from maybe 150 years ago, but
he made a very interesting comment about
this particular issue in Ephesians
chapter 2. He's specifically discussing
verse 15.
This is what he wrote. The idea is that
the ceremonial law of the Jews
on which they so much prided themselves
was the cause of the hostility
uh existing between them. In other
words, the ceremonial law was a bone of
contention between the Jews and the
Gentiles. Then he continues,
"This does not refer to the moral law."
In other words, the law of ordinances,
he's saying, does not belong to the
moral law, which was not the cause
of the alienation
and which was not abolished by the death
of Christ, but to laws, commanding
sacrifices, festivals, fasts, etc.,
which constituted the uniqueness of the
Jewish system. So, not all Christians
use these verses to say that the ten
commandments were nailed to the cross.
There are many Bible commentators that
understand that this is dealing with the
rights and ceremonies that the Jews had
which the Gentiles did not practice
which called caused a wall of
separation.
Uh I want to read one more uh passage
from scripture actually two verses from
scripture. The book of Hebrews, Hebrews
chapter 9 and verses 1 and 10, the word
ordinances is used. It's a not not the
same Greek word, but it's the same idea
that what we're dealing with in
Ephesians with the word ordinances is
referring to the ceremonial law which
passed away when Jesus died on the
cross. Hebrews chapter 9:1
speaks about the earthly system.
It says, "Then indeed even the first
covenant had notice the word ordinances
of divine service and the earthly
sanctuary." So it's talking about the
first covenant, the covenant of the
Jewish nation. It had a sanctuary and
that sanctuary had ordinances which has
to do with sacrifices and it has to do
with offerings and things like that,
feast days,
ceremonial Sabbath. etc. Now let's jump
down to verse 10.
Actually let's read verse nine for the
context. It that is the Old Testament
system was symbolic for the present time
in which both gifts and sacrifices are
offered which cannot make him who
performed the service perfect in regard
to the conscience. In other words, those
ceremonies did not really bring
forgiveness of sins. They only pointed
to the one who would bring forgiveness
of sins.
Now notice verse 10. This old system
which pointed forward to Christ was
concerned only with foods and drinks,
various washings and fleshly ordinances
imposed until the time of reformation.
time of reformation is in the new system
when Jesus Christ dies on the cross and
now his blood saves sinners. So, I hope
that this answer is useful to Lizzy who
has sent the question to us that this
passage is not dealing with the ten
commandments, the doing away of the ten
commandments because Jesus died on the
cross. It's dealing with the wall of
partition between Jew and Gentile and uh
how the blood of Jesus tore down that
wall because he fulfilled the meaning of
all the ceremonies that we find in the
Old Testament system.
Now we want to go to another uh couple
of questions actually that um come from
David K. Uh he is uh lives in Redwood
Valley, California. Uh th this is the
question. My question is what is the
difference between disciples
and apostles?
Are they the same thing? A disciple and
an apostle.
The question continues, I've always
understood
that disciples means to be disciplined
and the 12 disciples that were very much
so.
And then it continues, "And they were
also known as apostles because an
apostle has seen Jesus Christ face to
face in the flesh. Can you please help
me understand the difference between the
two?" So the question is, what is the
difference between a disciple and an
apostle? Well, the word disciple is
referring to a follower of Jesus, one
who follows the master, one who follows
Jesus. I'm just going to mention some
verses in passing here. Matthew 10 24
says, "A disciple is not above his
master." So in other words, a disciple
follows the master. A disciple follows
the steps of the teacher.
In Luke 14 26, we are told that the
disciple is willing to give up his life
and bear the cross. Well, that's exactly
what Jesus did. He gave up his life and
he bore the cross. So disciples should
follow Jesus uh the steps that Jesus
took. And then we find in uh Luke 14:33
it says that we if we cannot forsake all
we cannot be a disciple of Jesus. So uh
Jesus forsook all to save us. He left
everything he had in heaven. He forsook
everything and he became our savior. And
so we should follow the example of the
master in doing the same. Uh 1 John
chapter 2 and verse 6 doesn't use the
word disciple but um the concept is
there. It says he who says that he is in
Jesus needs to walk even as Jesus
walked. So basically a disciple is a
follower of Jesus. a person that
embraces Jesus Christ as savior and lord
and follows in his footsteps.
Now we need to bring to view also
Matthew chapter 28 and verses 18- 20
where Jesus gives the great commission
of what we specifically should you do as
his disciples. So I want to read Matthew
28 which uh these verses are very well
known to us. Matthew chapter 28 and
let's read um verses 18- 20. It's called
the great commission to the church. It
says, "And Jesus came and spoke to them,
saying, all authority has been given to
me in heaven and on earth." And then he
gives a command, "Go therefore and make
disciples of all nations,
baptizing them in the name of the Father
and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit.
So, we are to go and to make disciples
for Jesus Christ. How do we make those
disciples? Well, notice what it says in
verse 20. Teaching them to observe all
things that I have commanded you. In
other words, you're supposed to follow
what Jesus says if you're going to be
his disciple. So, it says, "Teaching
them to observe all things I have
commanded you. And lo, I am with you
always even to the end of the age. Now
that's the first part of the question.
The disciple simply is a follower of
Jesus. Someone who follows in his
footsteps. The second question is
regarding apostles.
Now when we talk about an apostle in the
New Testament, there are two meanings of
the apostle. One is a technical meaning,
a restricted meaning. An apostle is one
who has been an eyewitness
of Jesus Christ from the time that he
was baptized from the time of John the
Baptist till the time of the
resurrection an eyewitness of those
specific events.
We know that in the New Testament there
are 12
uh and we include Judas because he uh he
well maybe not Judas fully because he
did not see the resurrection of Christ
but the 11 who were faithful to the Lord
uh and Matias we're going to see from
Acts chapter 1 they were apostles
because they had seen the trajectory of
Jesus from the times of John the Baptist
till the time of the resurrection. Now
there's one other in the New Testament
that uh is also an apostle even though
he was not present with the 12 and
that's the Apostle Paul. We'll come back
to him in just a few moments. Now what
is an apostle in the technical sense of
the term? By the way there's only 12
which are the 11 plus Mias and then
there's also the Apostle Paul. So
there's 13 in the New Testament that are
used in a technical sense of the term.
What does Acts chapter 1 tell us that
qualifies an apostle to be such in a
restricted sense? Acts chapter 1 tells
us and we're going to read just here
verses 21 and 22 which are the
qualifications.
This is when they're going to elect
Matias who's going to take the place of
Judas. It says, "Therefore, of these men
who have accompanied us all the time
that the Lord Jesus went in and out
among us, beginning from the baptism of
John to that day when he was taken up
from us, one of these must become a
witness with us of his resurrection."
So notice in the technical sense of the
term to become an apostle an individual
had to be an eyewitness of Jesus Christ
from his baptism from the time of John
the Baptist till Jesus ascended to
heaven.
Now um of course we have the 11 who
remained faithful Matias and then we
have the case of the apostle Paul. I'll
just say something quickly about Paul.
Paul encountered Jesus Christ personally
on the road to Damascus.
And in Arabia, you can find this in
chapter 1 of Galatians verse 17. In the
desert of Arabia, he spent three years
receiving instruction directly from
Jesus Christ. Jesus Christ spoke to him
directly. And so the Apostle Paul
claimed to be an apostle. You ha you
have him saying that he's an apostle by
the will of God. He says, "I'm an
apostle by the commandment of God." By
the way, we are told in Galatians 1:17
as well as Galatians 4:24 and 25 that he
was in uh Arabia and there he was
instructed personally by Jesus Christ
and Christ undoubtedly showed him
everything that had taken place during
his lifetime. And so I trust that uh
this helps us understand the meaning of
the word apostle. By the way, there's a
general sense in which we're all
apostles because the word apost aposto
or uh apostello which is the verb means
to be sent and we're all sent in that
sense in a general sense we're apostles
but not in the technical sense of the
word. So we want to thank you for being
with our program today. Our time is up.
God bless you. Please join us in our
next program. I'd like to know. Take
care.
[Music]